YOUR  REPORTING.
NOW WE BRING IN IDF COLONEL
RICHARD HECT.
LET'S START WITH CLAIMS OF
CIVILIANS AND SOLDIERS CAPTURED.
HOW MANY PEOPLE BY THE IDF'S
COUNT HAVE BEEN CAPTURED BY
HAMAS?
>> A VERY SEVERE MORNING HERE
IN ISRAEL AND A COMBINED
OFFENSIVE BY HAMAS, GROUND, AIR
AND SEA.
NUMBERS ARE STILL NOT CLEAR.
THE NUMBERS ARE SUBSTANTIAL. A
VERY SEVERE MORNING AND WE ARE
VERY MUCH FOCUSED ON SAVING
FORCES.
WHERE THERE IS ONGOING FIGHTING
AND HANDLING THESE TERRORISTS.
HOPEFULLY BY THE END OF THE DAY
THERE WILL BE NO MORE LIVE
TERRORISTS INSIDE ISRAEL.
>> I THINK MANY ARE WONDERING
HOW THIS HAPPENED.
THERE IS ALSO VIDEO OF THE
BORDER FENCE BEING DESTROYED.
DO YOU AGREE THAT THIS WAS A
MASSIVE INTELLIGENCE FAILURE
AND IF YOU COULD EXPLAIN HOW
THIS UNFOLDED?
>> SO AGAIN FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
WE ARE NOT FOCUSED ON THAT.
I'M SURE THIS WILL BE TALKED
ABOUT A LOT.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED INTELLIGENCE BUYS
AFTER.
HAMAS HAS BEEN THREATENING FOR
YEARS.
SOMETIMES IT'S JUST TALK.
THEY ARE A TERRORIST --
INITIALED THEIR INTENTIONS THIS
MORNING.
A FULL COURSE INVASION.
PEOPLE ARE COMING ON THE GROUND
WITH TRUCKS.
WE ARE FIGHTING NOW TO GET
CONTROL BACK IN THE SETTLEMENTS.
>> THE LATEST NUMBER WE HAVE
FROM THE IDF ON ROCKETS BEING
FIRED IS 2000 WHICH IS A FEW
HOURS OLD.
DO YOU HAVE AN UPDATED NUMBER
FOR US
>> IT CROSSED THE 3000 LINE AND
IT WAS A VAST -- THIS MORNING.
THEY ARE STILL FIRING.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE CIVILIANS
THERE ON THE GROUND.
THE CIVILIANS WHO ARE UNDER
ATTACK.
WE HAVE REPORTS OF CIVILIANS
BEING FIRED AT.
WE HAVE VIDEOS OF A CAR BEING
FIRED AT AND WE KNOW THAT A
TANK WAS SEIZED FROM THE VIDEO
WE HAVE SEEN ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
WHAT IS BEING DONE TO SECURE
THOSE RESIDENTS IN THE
CIVILIANS WHO ARE BEING SEEN
RIGHT NOW IN SOUTHERN ISRAEL.
>> WE HAVE SPECIAL FORCES GOING
TO EACH ONE OF THESE LOCATIONS
WHERE THERE IS FIGHTING AND AS
WE SPEAK THERE ARE FIREFIGHTS
TO TAKE CONTROL AND CLEAN THE
AREA WHERE WE HAVE TERRORISTS
THAT CAME IN AND DID WHAT WE
DID.
THERE WAS A VERY GOOD UPDATE
THERE.
>> ONE THING IS THIS IS ONE
DIVISION AND WE HAVE SENT IN
MORE FORCES AND COMMANDERS AND
WERE TAKING THE SECURITY BACK
TO THE COMMUNITIES THERE AND
AGAIN, A VERY BAD MORNING.
YOU ARE SEEING THE PICTURES.
>> YOU HAVE AN ESTIMATE OF HOW
MANY RESERVISTS HAVE BEEN
CALLED UP?
>> TENS OF THOUSANDS.
>> I WOULD TELL YOU A LOT OF MY
FRIENDS -- ACROSS THE BOARD.
EVERYONE KNOWS THIS IS A DIRE
MOMENT.
>> QUICKLY CAN YOU TELL US THE
NUMBER YOU HAVE OF HOW MANY
HAVE BEEN CONFIRMED DEAD?
>> I CANNOT TELL YOU EXACT
NUMBERS.
IT'S A SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER.
>> WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THOSE
INFILTRATION ROUTES AND WHAT'S
BEING DONE TO SECURE THOSE AND
TO TRACK THEM DOWN SO THE
COUNTRY IS SECURE?
>> FIRST OF ALL WE ARE FULLY
DEPLOYED AND FOCUSED ON AIR
COVERAGE TO SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
WE DEPLOYED FORCES TO THE
INFILTRATION POINTS AND AGAIN
WE ARE SLOWLY SECURING THE AREA
AND TRYING TO TAKE CARE OF ALL
THESE PEOPLE THAT CAME IN.
>> I WILL ACCEPT THE ANSWER ON
BOTH.
THEY ARE SUBSTANTIAL AS IT
RELATES TO THE NUMBER OF DEAD
AND THE NUMBER OF THOSE
CAPTURED BUT I WANT TO GET
CLARITY.
WHEN YOU SAY YOU CANNOT TELL US
, YOU CANNOT TELL US BECAUSE
YOU WERE CHOOSING NOT TO GIVE
THE SPECIFIC NUMBER OR AT THIS
HOUR YOU ARE NOT CERTAIN OF THE
SPECIFIC NUMBER?
>> BECAUSE I'M IN CHARGE THE
IDEA AND THE EXACT DATA.
>> YOU SAY THE NUMBER OF
ROCKETS IS APPROACHING AND OF
COURSE AMERICANS KNOW THAT
ISRAEL IS NOT IS EQUIPPED WITH
THE IRON DOME.
HOW MANY OF THOSE HAVE HIT
THEIR TARGETS AND HAVE NOT BEEN
INTERCEPTED BY THE DOME?
>> THEY ARE DOING A GOOD JOB.
SOME OF THE ROCKETS THAT CAME
THROUGH WERE ACTUALLY DEBRIS
FALLING FROM -- AND THEY HAVE
DONE A GOOD JOB.
WE ARE DEPLOYING MORE
CAPABILITIES.
ALSO WE ARE LOOKING UP NORTH
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE READY
ALSO IN THE NORTH BECAUSE IT
CONVERSIONS OR OTHER THINGS
COMING FROM THE NORTH AND RIGHT
NOW THEY ARE DOING A GOOD JOB.
>> YOU CONFIRM ANY ATTACKS MADE
BY HAMAS AND BY AIR OR BY THOSE
PARAGLIDING IN?
>> THEY CAME PARAGUAY INTO
ISRAEL FROM THE GROUND FORCES.
IN ORDER TO LAND --.
IT WASN'T LIKE A YOU EV OR
SOMETHING ATTACKING --
>> HOW MANY VILLAGES ARE NOT
UNDER THE CONTROL OF IDF?
IF YOU CAN'T GIVE US A NUMBER,
HOW MANY OR IS IT A PRETTY BIG
NUMBER THAT ARE NOT UNDER
CONTROL?
>> SO AGAIN, THERE'S NOT MUCH
CONTROL.
THERE IS FIGHTING GOING ON.
SPECIAL FORCES ARE ENGAGING.
WE MENTIONED A FEW.
THERE IS A BASE AND THERE ARE
MANY LOCATIONS AND WE HAVE
FIREFIGHTS AND TERRORISTS
COMING IN AND PEOPLE HARMED AND
RIGHT NOW WE ARE FIGHTING TO
BRING THE SITUATION BACK TO A
STABLE STATE.
>> I HEAR THE EXPEDITION AND
ADJUST THE CLARITY.
YOU SAY THAT SOME OF WHAT HIT
THE GROUND WAS DEBRIS FROM
ROCKETS THAT WERE INTERCEPTED
BY THE DOME. HAVE THERE BEEN
ROCKETS THAT HAVE PENETRATED
THE DOME AND HIT THEIR TARGETS
ON GROUND?
>> THERE WAS A DIRECT HIT.
I STILL DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED.
PROBABLY MORE TO COME ONCE I
KNOW WE ARE UPDATING THIS.
AND THERE WAS ONE THIS -- WE
ALWAYS SAY IT'S NOT HERMETIC
DEFENSE.
HAMAS ALWAYS TRIED TO SATURATE
OUR SYSTEMS AND CREATE
DIVERGENCES.
NOT ONLY WITH USING GROUND
FORCES BUT ALSO SATURATING --
IN MULTIPLE DIRECTIONS.
TO INCLUDE IN A HOLY DAY FIRING
AT JERUSALEM.
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT CLOSE
TO 3000 ROCKETS IN SINGLE
DIGITS THIS FAR.
ROCKETS THAT HAVE HIT THEIR
TARGETS.
HOW MANY FIRED BACK IN
RETALIATION INTO GAZA?
>> RIGHT NOW THE AIR FORCE IS
ACTING IN GAZA TO TAKE CARE OF
THE --.
WE ARE RESPONDING TO THIS
INHUMANE ATTACK.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT YOUR
NEXT THAT IF THERE IS ONE.
CONSIDERING THAT THERE IS NO
SPECIFIC TRIGGER TO THESE
ATTACKS BY HAMAS THIS IS ALSO
COINCIDING COINCIDENCE OR NOT
WITH THE YOM KIPPUR WAR
ANNIVERSARY.
ARE YOU EXPECTING OR CONCERNED
OF ANOTHER ATTACK COMING FROM
THE NORTH OR SOMETHING WITH
LEBANON OR SYRIA?
>> I WOULDN'T GIVE THEM THE
CREDIT OF COMPARING IT TO THE
WAR.
THEY STAND BEHIND THEIR WORDS.
AND YES WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
NORTH.
WE SAW SOME SORT OF CONVERSIONS
AFTER THEY -- AND WE ARE READY
ALSO IN THE NORTH CASE THERE IS
A PALESTINIAN FACTION.
IN CASE THEY DECIDE TO COME
INTO THIS WE WILL BE READY.
SOMETHING WE ARE LOOKING AT AND
WE ARE READY FOR IT.
>> WHERE THERE'LL BE
SUBSTANTIAL GROUND FORCES GOING
INTO GAZA BEYOND THE AERIAL
ATTACKS THAT WE HAVE SEEN WILL
HE BE GOING IN ON THE GROUND?
>> I WILL LEAVE THAT TO OUR
PRIME MINISTER AND CHIEF OF
STAFF TALKING ABOUT ALL
MILITARY OPTIONS AND STILL NOT
-- AS WE SAY.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THIS
ASSESSMENT FROM SOME PEOPLE
THAT THIS IS YOUR 9/11?
YOU MAKE THAT COMPARISON?
>> I WILL LEAVE THESE BIG
QUESTIONS OF NARRATIVES AND
EVENTS IN HISTORIC COMPARISONS
TO WE GET OUR SECURITY BACK.
>> COLONEL WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE
TO THE RESIDENCE THERE? PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN FEAR FOR THEIR LIVES
AND CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR
SAFETY.
ONE WILL HELP COME AND OF
COURSE ALSO ANGRY BY THE FACT
THIS EVEN HAPPENED.
>> IDF IS A PEOPLE'S ARMY.
ALL OUR BOYS AND RIGHT NOW
BEING DEPLOYED THERE.
THEY ARE FIGHTING TO GET SAFETY
BACK INTO THESE PLACES AND
AGAIN IS NOT ONLY THE SOLDIERS,
IT'S ALSO THE BRAVE COMMUNITIES
THERE.
THERE WAS A COMMUNITY LEADER
THAT GOT SHOT AND KILLED AND
EACH COMMUNITY HAS RESERVISTS
THAT WHEN ERE IS A SECURITY
EVENT THEY DEPLOY AND ALSO RISK
THEIR LIVES SO RIGHT NOW AS WE
WE ARE FIGHTING.
IF WE DO THIS INTERVIEW WILL
HAVE A MORE